The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Well, welcome back to
computational systems biology.
We're back here today talking
about genome assembly.
How many people have ever
assembled a genome before?
In your spare time?
Anybody done any
genome assembly here?
One person?
I think genome assembly
is a fascinating topic.
And as you know, it's at the
bedrock of all modern biology.
We rely upon genome references
for almost everything in terms
of studying evolution, looking
at the structure of genes,
regulation of genes,
differences between individuals.
So it's really a very
fundamental concept.
And we're going to talk today
about two different ways
of assembling genomes.
And I think one of the takeaway
messages from today's lecture
is going to be that
genome assembly is more
of an art, in some
sense, than a science.
And one has to always
be a little bit
suspicious of a
genome assembly given
what you're about
to learn today.
And, of course, genome assembly
is becoming even more complex
because it used to be that
assembling the human genome
was the big task scientifically
in front of the community.
But now there are billions
of genomes waiting
to be sequenced-- all the
individuals in the world
and to try and interpret them.
And now you can get
your genome sequence
for between $5,000 and $10,000.
How many people here are tempted
to get their genome sequenced?
OK, I see about five
hands-- six hands.
Great.
So let's look at the science
behind genome assembly.
The basic concept
is that we're going
to collect some sequence
reads from the genome.
And we're going to
assemble them know
what are called contigs
for contiguous segments.
And these represent
uninterrupted portions
of the genome that are
completely covered by
reads that we believe
are contiguous.
These contigs then will be
paired together in scaffolds.
And scaffolds are like contigs
except that there are missing
parts between the
contigs in a scaffold.
We don't know what
those parts are.
But we're able to actually
glue them together
by using read pairs that allow
us to jump over the missing
parts because we have read
both ends of a molecule.
But we don't know
what's in the middle.
And then oftentimes we had
physical mapping technologies
where we actually can go back
and assign location scaffolds
to physical locations
on chromosomes
by using PCR sequences
like sequence tag sites
that physically locate
a particular sequence
identity to a physical location
on a particular chromosome.
And that provides us
with a total genome map.
So today we're
going to be talking
about how to go from a
hard drive full sequence
reads all the way down
to a set of scaffolds
that include assembled contigs.
And the way to think
about this once again
is that we start with
conceptually a single copy
of the genome.
We amplify this.
And in order to sequence it
on contemporary instruments,
we have to fragment it.
Now for those of you who were
in last Friday's recitation,
you heard Heng Li talking about
the idea that sequence reads
are getting longer.
In fact, sequence
reads up to 10 to 15
kilobases are now possible.
And sequence reads
even longer than that
are going to be possible,
which will greatly
simplify the assembly process.
But for now we're talking
about the challenge
of assembling short reads--
say 100 base pair reads off
of contemporary
sequencing instruments.
So we take the fragmented
reads and the notion
is that we know
that they're going
to align up like a puzzle.
And all we have
to do is line the
reads up to recover the read
sequence at the bottom--
the original genome sequence.
And I should add that many of
the illustrations in today's
lecture are from Ben Lagmi.
He was kind enough to allow me
to use them for today's talk.
So the goal is to come up with
that red sequence at the bottom
from the original set
of reads but, of course,
the read set that
we're talking about
is perhaps 200 million
reads or even a billion
reads as we'll see.
And so it's quite a tough task
to put pieces together given
that we really don't know
where they came from.
And we don't know
where they align
because we don't have
the red part to guide us.
Now today we're
going to be talking
about what's called
de novo assembly.
That means starting
from scratch.
You hand me your set of reads
for your favorite organism.
And we're going to
assemble it today.
That's different
than what's called
reference-guided
assembly because,
for example, if you're going
to re-sequence me or you,
there is a reference
human genome.
And it would be a simple matter
to take the reads from you or I
and map them back onto
the reference genome
as a guide to trying to
reassemble our genomes.
However, as you can
tell, if there's
a large structural variation
between the reference
genome and our genomes,
that process can fail.
So we're going to be talking
today about de novo assembly.
And in the process
of de novo assembly,
oftentimes we talk
about coverage,
which is on average how
many sequencing bases do
we have for every
base of the genome.
Here we have for this
little illustrative example
coverage of about 7x.
Now, at the origin of
the Human Genome Project,
some calculations were done
about how much coverage
was required to cover
the human genome.
And we talked last time
about library complexity.
This is a slightly
different idea,
which is we want to estimate
the probability the base is
uncovered.
So if we have the genome size
as G and the number of reads
as N and L is the
length of a read,
then N times L is the total
number bases that we have.
And that divided by the
genome is the average coverage
of a base.
And probably the probability
that a base is not covered
is the probability
we're going to observe
zero reads to that base,
which is e to the minus
lambda, roughly speaking, if
we use a Poisson approximation.
And therefore, the number of
uncovered bases it will have
is going to be roughly G
times e to the minus lambda.
The next calculations can
be thought intuitively
as the following way, which is
if we have N reads, if there's
going to be a gap
after a read, there
has to be an uncovered
base after it.
And so the number of gaps we're
going to have in our assembly
is roughly N times e
to the minus lambda.
So this is a back of
the envelop calculation.
And now if we take some of
our 1,000 genomes data, which
we previously used and asked how
well this approximation works,
we see something like
this where the x-axis is
the total number of reads and
the genome coverage in bases
is shown on the y-axis.
And these are all different
sequencing experiments.
So you can see there the
roughly green outline,
which follows the approximately
what we saw before
in this Lander-Waterman rule.
Could somebody tell
me what they think
is going on with the red lines
that actually don't match up
with that green line?
Anybody have any
ideas about why we
need more reads out
of those libraries
to get better coverage?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There is
probably some bias
when you're amplifying them?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
there's probably
skew in the original libraries
we talked about last time.
In fact, we talked
about last time
why the Poisson was not
a great approximation
for looking at libraries.
And in fact, we might
want to fit something
like a negative binomial
in this particular case.
So we've got our read set.
And we can also
talk about coverage
at a particular base, which is
different than average coverage
just to be clear that there are
two different kinds of coverage
that one can think about.
Here we see coverage
at T of level six.
And the other thing that
we need to be cognizant of
is that there are two
reasons that we might--
two common reasons why
we might actually see
reads that overlap but don't
agree at all positions.
The obvious reason
is that there's
an error in one of the reads.
We get quality
scores and so forth.
And that can help us
decide which is the truth.
But the other possibility
is that as you know,
you have one of each
of your chromosomes
from mom one from your dad.
And there could be
allelic differences
between these chromosomes.
So when we're doing
assembly, oftentimes we'll
find that these
allelic differences are
going to pop up in terms of
non-concordance of our reads.
And we'll have to
ultimately decide
if we want to make a single
diploid approximation
of a human genome or
we want to attempt
to assemble a diploid genome.
And if we're going to
do a diploid genome,
then we have to be
quite careful and use
somewhat different
assembly techniques.
But the common reference
genome is haploid.
It's only considering
one chromosomal sequence.
Is that clear to everybody?
OK, great.
So we're going to talk about two
general approaches to assembly
today.
We're going to talk about
overlap layout consensus
assemblers as exemplified
by a string graph assembler.
And we're also going to
talk about De Bruijn graph
assemblers today.
Now, overlap
consensus assemblers
were the first ones that
were used in the Human Genome
Project because reads
were longer back then.
However, as the number
of reads has increased,
those assemblers are
more difficult to utilize
in part because of the need to
find overlaps between reads,
as we'll see in a moment.
Whereas to De Bruijn
graph assemblers
are somewhat more efficient.
But they lose certain
kinds of information.
So let's begin with these
overlap layout consensus
assemblers.
And we're going to talk about
three steps to build contigs
and the scaffolding
step can be thought
of a similar between either
the overlap layout consensus
assemblers or De Bruijn
graph-based assemblers.
So we're going to first
build an overlap graph.
What's an overlap graph?
The essential idea
is that when we
take our collection
of reads, we look
for overlaps between
the suffix of one read
and the prefix of another read.
And if we think of
all of our reads,
we want to build a graph that
describes all of such overlaps.
And just to be
clear, I'm not going
to be talking today about
the reverse complement
of these reads.
Actual assemblers have
to represent that.
But it just duplicates
all the nodes at edges.
So we're going to
try and keep things
uncluttered by-- that's OK.
Thank you.
We're going to try and
keep things uncluttered
by not considering those today.
Now, one of the
challenges is how
to construct those overlaps.
And we're going to be
talking about graphs a lot.
So I thought it was worthwhile
just to review terminology.
We're going to represent overlap
graphs as directed graphs,
which consists of a
set of vertices, which
are the objects represented by
the circles in the edges, which
are the lines and a directed
edge goes from one vertex
to another.
And there's also an
equivalent representation
in notational form on the lower
part of the right of the slide
as well as a graphical
representation.
We're going to be using the
graphical representations
of these directed graphs today.
So the overlap graph is
simply a representation
of the overlap between reads.
And we pick a minimum
length of overlap at times.
But for the next few
slides, I'm simply
going to represent each
node as an individual read.
And the edges will be
annotated with the amount
of overlap between the reads.
So if I hand you a set of
reads, all we need to do
is to compute this
overlap graph.
We'll talk about how
to do that in a moment.
And you'll see graphically
then what comes out
of the process of computing
the overlap graph.
Now, it's possible
that overlap graphs
are cyclic because there
are circular chromosomes.
And as we'll see, it's also
possible to get a cyclic graph
out of a linear chromosome
if in fact there
are repetitive structures
in the chromosome that
cause a graph to
cycle back on itself.
So how to find overlaps
in efficient time
is a key problem.
And that's one of the reasons
that people have shied away
from using these
types of assemblers
is because the cost
of computing overlaps
has been thought to be N-squared
where N is the number reads
because you have to compare
all the reads to one another.
However, a really
clever algorithm
was devised that
used the technology
we talked about last time.
You recall the idea of the FM
index and Burroughs-Wheeler
transforms allowed us to index
a genome and then to look up
reads in time proportional
to the length of the read.
So here's the essential idea.
What we're going to do is we're
going to take all of the reads
that we collect.
And we're going to index them.
And we can do that
roughly at N log N time.
And after we've indexed
all of the reads,
then we can use that same
index to find overlaps very,
very efficiently.
And you can conceptualize this
as simply looking at a read
that you have in your hand and
looking it up in the index.
And you'll find all the
places that the suffix
or prefix of that read batches.
And you can trace back till you
find all the places it matches
where they hit an end of a read.
And those all correspond
to edges in the graph.
And it turns out that
this is so clever
that it eliminates
redundant edges.
So, for example, if
I have reads that
look like this where I have
read one overlaps with read
two which overlaps
with read three.
And read one and read
three also overlap.
An unreduced graph would have
a representation like this.
But it turns out
that we don't have
to do that because we can
simply reduce our graph to this
because we know that
read one and read three.
Actually, this is
the graph that we
would have that
would be unreduced.
We can reduce the graph to
eliminate this transitive edge
and simply represent
it in this fashion.
So when we use these
indices, we eliminate
these transitive edges
as we'll see momentarily.
So here's an example graph.
The sequence is
shown on the bottom.
The read lengths are
of length seven bases.
And we're going to consider all
overlaps a minimum size three.
And the edge label
is the actual length
of the overlap
between the reads.
And you can see
that at the outset
that these overlap graphs
are not necessarily simple.
That tracing a path
of the graph that
represents the original
string is not completely
and totally straightforward.
So we need to come up with a
way to articulate our metrics
for how to trace a path to the
graph to reconstruct a genome.
And that comes to the
question of layout,
which is how do we formulate
the problem of tracing
a path through an overlap graph?
So we'll first start with
the idea of the shortest
common superstring.
The shortest common
superstring of a string S
is the shortest string that
contains all the strings in S
as substrings for a particular
length of substring.
So, for example,
if we didn't have
the constraint of
shortest, then just
finding a string that contains
all the substrings is easy.
You just put them all together.
But if we want the
shortest, then we
need to be more thoughtful
in terms of the way
that we compute this
shortest common substring.
And here is an example of
the shortest common substring
for the substrings that I
have shown you up there.
So one way to think about
the assembly problem
is that we're trying to compute
the shortest common substring
of all the reads that we have.
And that will be the most
efficient representation
of those reads in
a linear sequence.
Now, we can describe
this problem
in terms of an overlap graph.
And if you think
about the way that we
would solve this in overlap
graph, in the shortest strings,
we want the maximum
amount of overlap.
So we want to trace a path
through the overlap graph that
gives us the largest
amount of overlap,
which gives us the
shortest string.
Right?
So if we simply
negate the overlaps,
we want to minimize the
total cost of the graph.
Now, it turns out
that this problem
is known to be a very hard
computational problem.
It's in the class of
something called NP-hard
because it's known as the
traveling salesman problem.
And when you think
about the fact
that we're going to have
hundreds of millions of reads,
this is not really
going to be tractable.
If we got rid of the
weights, and we simply
wanted to find a path
through the graph,
that's called the
Hamiltonian Path problem.
That's also NP-complete.
So the shortest common
substring is a way
to think about assembling.
But we can't really
necessarily optimize metrics
because it's going
to be intractable.
So think about ways of doing
this that are greedier.
So here's an example of how
we would compute the shortest
common substring starting
with the first string.
And each step along the
way, is a concatenation
of strings or a
collapsing of strings that
works towards building the
shortest common substring.
And we get the input string
and the output string.
So we could articulate
our assembly problem
as a greedy SCS algorithm
to try and put all the
reads together to come
up with a superstring.
And let me just describe to you
this will give us an intuition
into what goes wrong with
assembly in a moment.
But we do know there are
some bounds on this--
that if we actually did
the greedy algorithm, then
the assembly that we got would
be only two and a half times
longer than the true
shortest common substring.
That isn't really very
much comfort to us.
So we're going to have to
come up with different, more
heuristic ways of approaching
the assembly problem.
Here is another example.
Now, this is the one
that I want to show you
where we start with
a string at the top
where we're going to be looking
for minimum overlaps of three
and these are reads of six long.
And when we do this
greedy algorithm,
we come up with a
string, which is shorter
than the original beginning
string we started with.
Can somebody see
what happened here?
Why are we missing part
of the original string?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The reads
were short enough.
And they repeated enough
that we never found out
that it was of the length
that it actually was.
And so we just kind of
[INAUDIBLE] did it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the point
was that the reads were
too short to be able to
unambiguously identify
the number of repeats
of long that we
had in the original sequence.
That's absolutely correct.
So we're not able to
disambiguate what was going on.
And perhaps if we went
back to our graph formalism
we could solve this
problem, right?
Because here we have our
graph and the overlaps
are written in on the
edges of the number
bases that each one of
these reads overlaps.
And all we need to do is
to trace through this graph
to find the original string.
So here is one
tracing, which gives
a total overlap of 39, which
actually faithfully reproduces
the original string, right?
However, that's not
the best tracing.
A better tracing through this
graph or path through the graph
would be this, which
gives us more overlap
and gives us a shorter string.
But as we know, even
though it's better
according to this metric,
it isn't really optimum
because it gives us
the wrong answer.
It's better but wrong.
So we're going to have to take
into account other things when
we do our assembly and
our tracing of this graph
to be able to come up with
the best possible assembly.
So if we increase
the read length
as was pointed out to
span appropriately,
we will be able to reconstruct
the original sequence.
And the point of this
example is that we
need to consider this when
we're thinking about recovering
repeat structures in genomes.
So if we don't have
long enough reads,
in this case reads
of length 8, we're
not going to go to recover
the original repeat structure.
And if we look at this,
repeats are really
the bane of assemblers
in some sense.
And as you know, roughly
50% of the human genome
is repetitive content.
So we need to be very, very
careful in terms of the way
that we utilize reads to
be able to recover the best
approximation of
our genome sequence.
So here's another
example where we
look at l is minimum
over length and k
is the length of the reads.
And you can see the
sequence that we're
trying to recover-- It
was the best of times
it was the worst of
times and the output
from our greedy SCS assembler.
And as you can see,
we need to get up
to a read length of
13 characters for us
to be able to properly assemble
that original sentence.
So the essential message
here is that unless you
have reads that are long
enough to span repeats,
you're not going
to go to recover
the original sequence exactly.
And this can be also thought
of in the following example.
Imagine you have repeats
that are tandem repeats out
at the end of a sequence.
And we're using the
English language
here because it's easier
to see than if I put up
a bunch of genomic sequence.
But, of course, the
principles are the same.
You can see that
unless we have reads
that actually are anchored
and unique sequence
and span out towards
a repetitive sequence,
we can't really tell
how many times the word
bells is repeated.
Another possibility
is that we can
actually coming from both sides.
And if we can anchor our reads
and unique sequence on both
the left and the right side
of a repetitive element,
then we can figure out how many
copies of something like bells
is present.
But in the absence of that,
we really can't do it.
In fact, we wind up with a
structure looks like this.
We wind up with-- there
it is-- a structure where
we have-- let's
just say that there
are four different
stretches of genome
in disparate parts
of chromosomes
and we repeat sequence
in the middle.
The blue parts of
the chromosomes
are unique sequence.
And the red parts are
repetitive sequences.
What will happen is that if
the reads aren't long enough,
we'll be able to find out in
each one of the four locations
that we've gone from unique
sequence to repeat sequence.
And then we will get
lost in the middle
of this identical
repeated sequence.
And then on the
right-hand side we'll
once again transition back
from repeated sequence
to unique sequence.
But we won't know how to put
things together in the middle.
Right?
We won't be able
to figure out what
the path is through these
repetitive elements.
So that's the essential point
I'd like to make about repeats.
And we can now turn to
the question of layout
and how to process an overlap
graph towards making contigs.
This is the actual layout graph.
When we think about
that sentence up there.
And we say the minimum over
that length is four characters.
And we have seven-character
reads out of the sequence.
You can see it's a
pretty messy graph.
If we clean up the graph by
removing the redundant edges,
the edges like
this that span over
reads and are implied
by other reads,
we can remove edges that
are transitive over one
reads or two reads.
Now, my presentation
is going to talk
about how to remove these edges.
However, as I said
at the outset,
if you use the algorithm
by Simpson et al.,
you actually don't generate
these transitive edges
in the first place.
But assuming that you
didn't use an algorithm
and you did generate
them, you want
to get rid of these
transitive edges like so.
And it starts getting
somewhat simpler
as you begin
simplifying the graph,
removing these transitive edges.
And then we can remove
edges that skip two nodes.
So here's what happens after
you remove the single transitive
edges in this graph.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it seems that the
transitive and verbal edges
gave us a little bit more
information about the genome.
Do we lose some useful
ordering principles by--
PROFESSOR: They provide
redundant information.
They don't really provide
any additional information.
It's the same linear sequence
that's implied by those edges.
Any other questions?
So we can then remove
edges that span two nodes.
And we get an even
simpler graph like this.
Now this is beginning to look
more tractable because we
can look at this and we
can output contigs that
correspond to linear
portions of the graph, which
should be linear sequence.
And when we do that what we
wind up with are two contigs.
And there's just a bit of
problem in the middle, which
is that we're unable to
resolve the bit in the middle
and as a consequence,
we know that that
is the number of terms that
are in that original sentence
because we didn't
have a read long
enough to be able
to resolve that.
The other problem
that we can have
in doing this kind of
layout is that when
there are portions of
the genome that occur
or sequences in the genome that
occur multiple times, when we
actually do this
layout, we may find
that the portions
of the genome that
occur in two disparate locations
line up with one another.
And it may be that as you
exit the portion that's
shared you get a
mismatched base.
So that mismatch
could be because you
have disparate parts of
the genome that actually
have very similar sequence.
Or it could be
that you had a read
error at the end of your read.
And it's difficult to tell the
two apart except by the amount
of coverage that you have.
We'll talk about
how to prune graphs
like this in a few moments.
But in any event, assuming
that we have pruned the graph,
we have done our overlap.
We've done our layout.
We've found our paths to
the graph for our contigs.
And then what we find
is that for each contig,
we have many reads.
And we're going to
take those reads.
And we're going to look at them.
And as you recall,
we could either
have errors causing
disagreement among the reads.
We could have allelic
differences between mom and dad
causing those errors, well, not
really errors-- differences.
And then we can take
a consensus to come up
with what the haploid genome is.
So that's the essential idea
of a overlap layout consensus
assembler.
We compute the overlap graph.
During the layout phase we
actually simplify the graph.
And we find pass through it.
And during the consensus
phase, we take our reads,
and we build a consensus
sequence of the genome.
And as I said, this graph
building can be slow.
Although, we'll
talk about how slow
it is here in just a moment.
And the challenge is that
modern sequencing data sets
are hundreds of
millions of reads.
So let's talk about a
contemporary overlap-based
assembler-- something called
the stream graph assembler,
which is done over at
the Sanger in the UK.
And there are three separate
steps it goes through.
The first step is it
tries to correct reads.
And the way it does
this is it actually
looks at all the
k-mers that occur in
reads-- it tries to find
sequences that are very, very
rare and find sequences
that are nearby
in sequence base
that aren't as rare.
And it can correct bases that it
believes are sequencing errors.
The next step is
assembly once it
has taken all these
reads and corrected them.
It indexes all the
reads as I suggested
earlier using an FM index.
And then it can find the overlap
from that FM index directly.
And part of the assembly
process is throwing away
duplicate reads
and throwing away
reads that have
low quality scores.
So that's the filtering step.
It then has the set of
contigs that it has generated.
And it does something
quite interesting
to find the scaffolds is that
it takes the contigs it's
assembled in terms
of linear sequence.
And it completely re-indexes
them once again using
an FM index.
And then it takes all the
reads that you started with.
And it maps them back
onto the contigs.
And by mapping the paired
reads back on to the contigs,
it can actually figure
out what contigs
should be formed into scaffolds
where there are holes that
are breached by
these longer reads.
So it's using the FM indexed
both for correction to find out
nearby k-mers for
assembly to find overlaps
and for scaffolding to
put things together.
And it does its indexing
three different times.
And just to give you an
idea of how long it takes
for a human-sized
genome, it's actually
quite expensive in
terms of CPU time.
It takes many days
have elapsed time
to assemble an entire
human genome right now.
And it's thousands of
CPU hours to actually put
a genome together
starting from scratch.
OK, so that's the essential idea
of an overlap-based assembler.
Are there any questions at all
about overlap-based assemblers?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in the
case of an error ,
it's obvious how
you would call that.
But in an allelic difference,
hypothetically, there
would be 50% of the reads would
have one and 50% of the reads
would have another.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: So in that case
does it assemble-- do you
just bias towards whichever
ones weren't easily amplified?
Or do you assemble
two sequences?
PROFESSOR: Most assemblers
produce a single sequence.
And I don't know how SGA decides
between the different alleles
because I don't recall what
the paper said they did.
But they have to
essentially flip
a coin to come up with
a haploid sequence.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You said there was
three different times that you
index.
What are the three?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
the question was
I said there are three
different they indexed.
They indexed at the
outset to find errors.
They indexed the second time
to do the overlap computation.
And they indexed the
third time to realign
all the original reads to the
contigs they have to figure out
which contigs to put
together into scaffolds.
Right?
But they have this essential
foundational platform,
which is the FM index.
And so they use that
over and over again
to be able to do the assembly.
These are all great questions.
All right, any other questions
about overlap-based assemblers.
And you can see that if you
think about how much coverage
they get out of an assembler
like this, it's actually,
we'll compare all the
assemblers at the very end.
But if you look at the
number of bases of autosomes
and the X chromosome
covered by an assembly,
you can consider
that as a function
of the minimum alignment
length to a referenced genome.
And as the minimum
alignment length goes up,
that means you have to match
longer and longer portions
of the reference genome for
your assembly contig to count.
You can see that the number
of bases dropped somewhat.
In here they're
showing that they
do better than another
assembler called SOAPdenovo.
But they do get a
fairly good coverage.
On the other hand,
they don't get coverage
anywhere near as good as
Lander-Waterman might suggest
because the coverage
should suggest
that the probability
of uncovered base using
Lander-Waterman would be roughly
e to the minus 40th-- something
like that.
And e to the minus 40th is like
4 times 10 to the minus 18.
So they're not
anywhere near what
we would think the
Lander-Waterman bound would
be for assembly.
So we've talked about these
overlap-based assemblers.
Now I'm going to turn to
De Bruijn graph assemblers.
How many people have heard
of De Bruijn graphs before?
Anybody?
One person?
So before we talk about De
Bruijn graphs themselves,
let's just talk terminology.
So when I'm using
terms we're all
on the same page where we were
talking about k-mers where
the word mer is from
the Greek "part."
And we talk about 4-mers
of an original sequence
as a sequence that's
four bases long.
And we can think about
all of the 3-mers
of an original sequence.
So we talk a lot about k-mers.
And a k minus 1-mer is a
substring of length k minus 1
obviously from a k-mer.
So if we think about the
collection of reads--
here these are our
super-simple economy sequencers
producing reads of only
length three, which
is pretty desperate.
But at any rate we'll go
with that for the time being.
And we think about
each one of these reads
as having a left k minus 1-mer
and a right k minus 1-mer.
We split them into
two halves that way.
And we're going to build a
graph that is as follows.
We're going to take all of the
k minus 1-mers-- in this case
the 2-mers.
And for each read,
we're going to draw
an edge between its left
2-mer and its right 2-mer.
OK, once again, for
each read, these sort
of anemic,
three-base-pair reads,
we're going to draw an
edge between its left 2-mer
and its right 2-mer.
And they overlap in one base.
So all of the graphs that are
De Bruijn graphs, the edges
represent an
overlap of one base.
OK?
So if you look at the
graph at the bottom,
that represents the
overlaps present
in the original sequence.
You note that we have
AA as one of the 2-mers.
And its left half and right half
obviously overlap by one base.
The triple-A read has
AA as its left read
and AA as a right read--
thay overlap at one base.
And that's why we have that
circular edge from A to itself.
And the next edge
from AA to AB comes
from the next
read-- the AAB read.
So each edge then represents
an overlap of one base.
And therefore, each
edge represents
a unique k-mer sequence.
So the way to think
about this graph
is it that all of the edges
represent the original reads.
And we have represented the
k minus 1 words as the nodes.
OK?
So we can take this graph
then and generalize this idea.
And if we look at
how the graph changes
as we add more
structure, here you
see that we've added an extra b.
And we get another edge in the
graph back to the same node.
So when we're
building these graphs,
if possible, we reuse a
node that already exists.
Now the way to think
about coming back
to the original sequence
is finding a path
through this graph and emitting
sequence as we trace the path.
And we would like
to have a path that
traverses all of the nodes.
And so we have some
definitions here,
which is that a node is
balanced if its indegree equals
it's outdegree.
And you can see that not all
the nodes are balanced down
the graph of the lower,
right-hand corner.
And it's connected
if all the components
or nodes can be reached.
And a Eulerian walk visit
each edge exactly once,
which is what we would like to
actually take a De Bruijn graph
and emit a genome sequence.
Now, not all graphs
have these walks.
And graphs do our Eulerian.
And we won't distinguish
different types
of these graphs.
And if a graph has two
semi-balanced nodes
and all the rest of
the nodes are balanced,
then it will have
a walk through it.
So if we think about
our original graph,
there are two arguments
for it having such a walk.
The first argument is
that we show the walk.
And the second is that we
have two semi-balanced nodes
and the rest of the
nodes are balanced.
So the reason that
we care about this
is that we want to study
cases where this goes wrong.
So to build a De Bruijn
graph of a genome,
we're going to take our
original sequence reads.
And we're going to take
all the k-mers that
occur in those reads.
And we're going to add
edges to a De Bruijn graph
based upon those k-mers.
So if we have a read like
this, and we consider
a k-mer in the read,
we're going to add an edge
in the graph between
the left k minus 1-mer
and the right k minus 1-mer.
And we'll do that for every
single k-mer in the read.
Now note what this does is
it destroys some information.
It destroys information
about the ordering
of certain of the k-mers in this
read just destroying their read
contiguity in order to make
some simplifying assumptions
to represent the
sequence ordering
of these k minus
1-mers in the graph.
So we build the
graph in this way
and if I were to build
the graph like this,
what is the minimum
sequence overlap for two
reads to actually share an
edge in the resulting graph?
Can anybody see how
long the sequence
must be in the
second read for it
to actually overlap at
edge with the first read?
Well, if this second read
also has a k-mer, right?
It's going to produce another
structure just like this one
if these two do overlap.
And thus the edge produced
by this read and the edge
by this read will
overlap like this.
And thus all of the nodes that
came from this part of read one
will feed into this graph.
And then all the
nodes to come out
of this k-mer from the
purple read will come out
of it like so, right?
And thus when we're
tracing the graph,
the idea is that the
graph will be connected.
And we'll be able to
come between these reads
and reconstruct
the sequence that
was suggested by the overlap.
The thing, however, you should
note in this-- yes, question?
AUDIENCE: So you're
picking two k minus 1
reads there-- are those
from different reads?
Or from the white read?
PROFESSOR: No, it's
from the white read.
These are the 2k minus 1-mers
that came out of this read.
So they actually overlap.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
but then you were
talking about how the one
was purple in that case.
PROFESSOR: Right, well, this
is the same sequence let's say.
This is the same, exact
sequence down here.
So if it's the same,
exact sequence,
it will have the
same k minus 1-mers.
And when we build the graph
if a node already exists,
we reuse it.
And thus if we
reuse the nodes that
were created when we
built the graph nodes
and edges for the white read,
then when the purple read comes
along, we're going to
put another edge here
between these two k minus 1-mers
because they are contained here
as well.
So these are identical
sequences to this
because these two reads overlap.
And this part is the same
sequence as that part.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so why do
you need k minus 1-mers
if you have overlapped k?
PROFESSOR: Because
the way we're finding
these overlaps is
through the graph.
And we're not indexing
things of size k, right?
We're indexing things
of size k minus 1.
In each edge represents
a sequence of length k
because we know this
sequence and this sequence
are overlapped by one base.
So when we find an edge that's
the same between the white
and the purple read,
we know that they're
overlapping by k bases.
Is that making sense to you?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, OK, so
let's try it again.
AUDIENCE: You can keep going.
PROFESSOR: No, it's OK.
Let's just start with the purple
read to start for a moment
because I think if
you have a question,
other people may
have a question.
So we have this sequence, which
is this sequence right here,
right?
And then we have
this sequence, which
is the sequence right here.
They overlap by one base.
And so we put an edge between
them like this in the graph.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Don't they overlap
by more than one base?
They can only contain
one base from each k-mer.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
That's what I meant.
Yeah.
And then the same thing
is true down here.
And so we will find this k minus
1-mer and this k minus 1-mer.
And then they overlap.
For genome assembly, we
record the forward and reverse
complement reads in twin nodes.
And we're not going to
show those because it just
complicates our
graphs without really
adding any illustrative power.
And we always choose k to
be odd so that a node can't
be its own reversed complement.
And here is the graph growing
if we think about k equals 5.
So we have reads of length five.
And we are adding
sequences to the graph.
And you note that
the graph is acyclic
until we get to the
repeated sequence.
And we get to the second long
the sequence comes back around
begins a looping back on itself.
And if we consider the last
part of this De Bruijn graph
construction, then we wind
up with the finished graph
on the right-hand side.
And you can see the
multiplicity of the edges
correspond to the
number of times
the long is repeated
in this graph.
So once again, repeats are
causing the circular structure,
which only could be resolved if
we had sufficiently long reads,
which we don't have in
this particular case.
However, if we consider
perfect sequencing
we always have a
path to the graph.
And the reason is
that the leftmost part
of the genome, so to speak,
is going to be semi-balanced.
And the rightmost part is
going to be semi-balanced.
And all the parts in between
are going to be balanced.
So the k minus 1-mer on the
very left end is semi-balanced
and the k minus 1-mer on
the right is semi-balanced.
And all the nodes in
between are balanced.
Now, this does not allow
for errors of course.
And we talk about following
this Eulerian walk
to find the original sequence.
But the question we can ask
ourselves is whether or not
this walk always
really corresponds
to the original genome sequence.
It turns out I can show
you this example, which
is we have this graph
for this sequence.
And there are two different
walks through this graph.
And the two different
walks produced
two different sequences.
And they depend
upon which way you
start walking from the node AB.
So once again, here we
have seen that even when
we have a path to the graph,
the path may not be unique.
It may not be able to
generate the original sequence
that we started with.
So the other problem
we can have when
we are building a graph like
this is that gaps in coverage
can create holes in the graph.
So if we omit
certain of our reads,
we'll come up with a graph
that is broken into two parts.
And this corresponds
to the idea that we're
going to create two different
contigs that are contiguous
sequence but will be unable
to fill in the middle part.
OK?
So we also can have differences
in coverage of a graph
when we have extra reads
at particular locations
in the genome.
And that causes the degrees on
the individual nodes to vary
and causes us to not be able
to rely upon the indegree
and outdegree as an
absolute metric for how
to trace a path
through the graph.
And the other thing is that
if you have differences
between the chromosomes,
which we talked about
last time in our overlap
layout consensus assembler,
it also can cause
graphs to split apart
and to have subgraphs
that correspond
to one allele versus the
other allele, which is present
perhaps in the main graph.
All right, so it's
actually the case
that these graphs are attractive
for a very important reason,
which is there extraordinarily
efficient to build.
That is in order to
build a graph like this,
you need to take each one
of these k minus 1-mers
and actually find the node,
which you can do by hashing
and then put the
edges into the graph.
And so you find that you need
to put in an edge and two nodes
for each k-mer.
And if you have a hash map that
encoded these nodes and edges,
it's constant time work.
So you wind up
with a graph which
costs order of the
number of reads to build.
So it's a linear time
graph construction problem.
Recall that our last
overlap construction,
we thought we could
get down to N log N.
And here is an example of
sub-setting part of the lambda
phage genome using a De
Bruijn graph assembler.
And you can see that
roughly the time required
to assemble parts
of the genome is
linear in the amount of genome
sequence that you give it.
So these assemblers were
favored early on in the days
of short-read assembly in part
because they were so efficient.
And typically in
some of the projects,
you have very high coverage.
And so you wind up with
graphs that actually
have a huge number of
edges between nodes.
And this can be
summarised in terms
of a graph that simply
annotates the edges
with the number of instances.
And so you have a weighted graph
on the right-hand side, which
is easier in some sense to
trace because we can now
begin to eliminate low-coverage
edges as potential anomalies.
But the essential idea is to
trace these graphs to produce
the ultimate genome sequence.
And in order to
do so, we may need
to do some error correction.
So we talked earlier about the
idea that if we have an error,
we're going to actually produce
a portion of the graph that
hangs off into outer space.
And we can cut these
dead-end tips of the graph
off if they are low coverage
because they presumably
correspond to errors.
If we get an error in
the middle of a read,
we can wind up with a so-called
bubble in the graph, which
once again is low coverage.
And we can get rid of these
bubbles in a similar fashion.
And it's also possible to get
chimeric edges of the graph.
And those can be caused
by errors as well.
And we can clip those edges.
So there are different
kinds of error correction
we can do in the graph.
These are all quite heuristic.
Each assembler has its
own set of heuristics
for how to deal
with graph anomalies
and how to eliminate edges in
the graph to permit assembly.
But these are getting
rid of dead-end tips
and popping bubbles and
getting rid of chimeric edges
are important things to
consider for any assembler.
So the limitations
of these graphs
are the idea that
we're immediately
splitting these reads into this
k-mer representation, which
is destroying information.
And in order to
overcome this, one
of the things that people have
done in these De Bruijn graph
assemblers is to take
the original reads
and to map them back
on to the graph.
So when you're
attempting to trace
the path through the
graph, what you do
is you take the original reads.
You thread them
through the graph.
And you know that
the original read
represents contiguous
genome sequence.
So it provides you with
a path through the graph
that you know is good.
People have been
doing this in part
because they didn't want to
go to the full overlap graph
implementation
because of the cost.
But I think that these overlap
graph implementations now
are sufficiently sophisticated
that I personally
would use them instead of a
De Bruijn graph assembler.
And so the trade off
really centers around
speed and space versus accuracy.
So we can look at some
example assemblers
and look at their performance.
But before I do that and
we leave De Bruijn graphs,
are there any other questions
about De Bruijin graph
assemblers?
AUDIENCE: I have one.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: How long
is k typically?
PROFESSOR: We're going
to talk about that.
The k typically is somewhere
around 60-- something
like that-- Somewhere
in that neighborhood.
It's actually-- it
has to be odd, right?
So 61, 57-- something like that.
Good question.
Any other questions about
De Bruijin graph assemblers?
So once again returning
to over our architecture,
we have these reads.
We need to produce contigs.
In the case of
overlap graphs, we're
going to trace the
overlap graphs.
In the case of De
Bruijn graphs, we're
going to trace the
De Bruijn graph.
For scaffolding, we can use
the read pairs to put scaffolds
back together again.
And here is some comparison
of the performance
of these various assemblers.
So the first assembler--
SGA-- is an overlap layout
consensus-style assembler.
Velvet/Abyss and SOAPdenovo
are all De Bruijn,
graph-based assemblers.
So these are all
contemporary assemblers
that people use for
assembling genomes.
An important metric
for assemblers
is something called N50,
which is the size of a contig
or scaffold where at that length
or larger 50% of the bases
are present in scaffolds
of that length.
So, for example, for SGA, they
say that scaffold N50 size
is 26.3 kilobases, which
means that in scaffolds
of length 26.3
kilobases or larger,
half of the bases
of the assembly lie.
So the larger the N50 is,
the larger the scaffolds
are that cover things.
And you want larger and
larger scaffolds or contigs
so that you have fewer
gaps in your assembly.
So the N50 number is a
principle comparison metric
when one is thinking
about assemblers.
So in this particular case,
for SGA the overlap metric
was that the reads had to
overlap by at least 75 bases
or more.
And these were
100-base pair reads.
You can see the
details on the read
data on the bottom line there.
So as long as the reads
overlap by 75 bases,
they were put
together in the graph.
And the De Bruijn
graph assemblers
each had their own
optimum number for k.
And the way that you tune
these parameters is you
run the assembler on
a range of k values.
And you see which k value
produced the assembly
with the highest N50.
And you pick that k.
Can anybody think
of a reason why
it is that although
these are all
roughly in the same ballpark,
different assemblers might have
different k values given that
the underlying technology is
quite similar?
Any guesses about
what is going on here?
Well, we know that the
differences in the assemblers
really are rooted in the
way that they are processing
the graphs and the way that
they are simplifying them.
And therefore,
one has to imagine
that the differences lie in the
post-processing of the graph
once it's built and that
certain assemblers like larger k
values.
Whereas other ones can
tolerate smaller k values.
And you can see if we look
at the running statistics
for these, that the
performance of SGA
if you look at the
reference bases covered
by contigs greater
than one kilobase
is roughly comparable to
all the other assemblers.
But its mismatch
performance is much better.
That is the other assemblers
are producing-- well,
I take it back except
for SOAPdenovo.
But it does quite a
good job at correcting
reads in coming up with
the correct sequence.
The last lines however tell the
story about running time, which
is that the overlap
consensus assembler is taking
41 hours of CPU time for
C. elegans genome assembly.
Whereas the other assemblers,
the De Bruijn assembler
are running much faster.
So the thing that I
wanted to emphasize today
was that once you have
the final graph whether it
be an overlap graph
or a De Bruijn graph,
which represents possible
ways of putting back together
again the jigsaw
puzzle, it still
is an art to be able to
build an assembler that
uses appropriate heuristics
to trace the graph
to come up with a
genome sequence.
And I think another
lesson is that repeats
are very problematic.
With short reads, we really
cannot resolve repeats exactly.
As a consequence, when we think
about any reference genome
that we're dealing
with, if we consider
the size of the reads that were
used to assemble that genome,
then we need to
be mindful of what
that tells us about
whether or not
the repeat structure that
we're observing in the genome
is really an accurate
rendition of what's
going on in the genome itself.
And finally, I think
that we've talked today
about the problem of
assembling genomes
from a set of reads
that represent
a uniform, single individual
albeit with possibilities
of differences of
alleles between mom
and dad in a diploid organism.
However, environmental
sequencing
where one takes up sea
water or other samples
and sequences all
the organisms in it
and then attempts to assemble
those organisms de novo
admits the
possibility that there
are many different genomes
that you're considering.
And that, of course,
creates a whole new set
of research problems,
which I think
are unsolved in part
because of the read links
that we're currently
dealing with.
Are there any final
questions about assembly?
OK, great.
Well, we will see
you then on Thursday
where we will talk about
ChIP-seq and IDR analysis.
Until then, have
a great Wednesday.
Thank you very much.